[Music]
came mechanics is full for them with four
evens correct
so to put and ida under fade
mentor at no to the series is an
absolute
brilliant discovery made in the early
20th century the nineteen quinty's in
1820 fisher's so can it be that this  five
special way of dressing the motion and
all the properties of the tania's particles
in the yuniver
the items the molecules the photos
whatever you take this small tari and
light
it first control but iv'e macro
certificate tions science gold quantum
mechanics
so what fits  then this card i made a
choice is it came week and i is correct
arrest him and my question is a
student or physics or quartet us but
slater
that nicknamed what elektroon salt
came public and think as the 4 th for
electronic
way to apart eagles  notably the
nucleus or leave it blank canvas shows this
event
so off poorer they prices have my type
set of cards that as usb controller at
quantum mechanics
like it where people he  bben if you then
the car that I that is mechanics nos
journal and mama baked my size x or
did the we know arrive realize this must
be the case the entire world is control
there I came there nothing so acomplia criticism
rations and
or something like that what have  a cake that en
soeris customer weekend was discovered
people realize that was a fundamental
difficulty with
meaning the crèche and what it means
hot
writer came known that they crash with
jacket wet paper turn on was what is reality
so that we here discussions
that generally in nice people
direct newsman
and and churn
and then house mountain with our einstein and
many others were present in the
discussions and their here te
discussions  and bike what could we
knowledge lily was where it makes sense
on and d greece and agreements and
no it was right cm x sense and so
many many testicle agreements e  n then
keep those rica collections' keep
splashing cosmo
harry push jaw read your heels you
preach you come experiment and the file
read about that
and he got someone to make a mess
because big set end out dark
living so there is and now the requirement is
crash what what is it ri not there 3 min
what is a particle
what is and views and them to your channel
sketches or this kind of
wise position on the page what is something
velocity our momentum and then that impetus
become computing' just about the people
amount of discussions  in copenhagen and
then we make a new track hans
famous institute out of a tough one a new
track was a center of the sith cabinets
in the sense what is it you just
don't ask ashens
dead bait what it ria a belt once jazz
what  that i races her and next to her
you k claesen's
and then you won't be a oh that's toe is
all you're not around again and all the
fiorini protect
what the ground and oh was no economist
also did it an attack and so their
great  moo  d was dead set crashing and
by sveti naum ehm he this cream pie
this ob mah dat cabinet
michel is for for depression a because now
what is the risk of a review pieces
have
kdz hef input for more more
in leather times about the fascinus of
reality built there that i see you what y'all
firth that the hall reported two of
the font whirls that descried all passes
like us happened when carnation the
ocean ere it was he's a pilot be
and
even for post from the time that the
scrupled press  cry particles wooden move
it got the right the belief dat ar stil
was
hi up high was da da daht dah shoeby and
real-world so dig used as you just
one universe
one je verse content die particles people
planets stars galaxy's bee al reilly and
spirit  is not true
that year 3v construction reality what evc
town than your precious self
would rather also site of the main discussion there
year at people we so you put he
that there centimes
fuzzy and outside reality and you
put that  here really already so
quantum mechanics wat da's het c dit
tells you how to handle the statistics
of particles it doesn't tell you how one
single party op die he is free
confusion pastry cake dough your experiment
with millions of particles or je t
just experiment  theory pieten million
times under his particle
i am so very precise and say
yes at actually already
compile collisions insurance company
insurance company can not predict et al ben
je wil die of whether or not you
will have excellent
dat ik death note is has  million
people of 1000 people are you even
per cent ik wil die en de during which
time peewits
ergonomic recent jordy's people will
have excellent and that's all day care
about to determine the cause of a
shines so in that sense came weekend who
works a soccer  that
and black you don't have to where insurance
company and finally then what this
has become digital reality is totally mysterious
en evening will cry street view close
spain  e what customer week and is there send
reality and you agree so nothing mystery
is in south crazy exams came
but it works and how i like teske well
that we have the long to modify the
it's so beautiful facts came mechanical
represents a to the  mood of nature
at the most fundamental level whoever
her breath you roamed molecules box atoms
through the males a means of adam's
the breaths of sap atoms
particles thumbs up the all-in particles
to maggot of sap sap at talpa te gast and
dino of  guess max what what
reality is in stil something that i
don't understand claim to the situation
how many population many more the case may
not come to change it overnight
who do respect that the massi your father and
to 4 ii civilization
that together  expressed as continue with you
haven't got it and discount uwv work
difficult or not' idea that that moon
panache to meet arises your suspension
for the series to project or service and
they say i can create now he is so many
of those  the  second single 4u that on this
man is just two extreme each one
sold so this so take and in that
respect to one to point out that good
oil a few hundred thousand years ow
to the all its prime something outside and
inside yerseke boys what you batter
crazy
child somewhere was just like it was so and so
i that on about just a couple or else
or even or yes that's enough one
in evolutionary times live on
he sex is it for billions of vs this
june vs house
access the cement billions of here  is
a fourteen 914 defines is that
one the drivers that ufos in the
future will polly become much older
as have lots of time to taste in
the mood and offshore the hands fresh
that's from
how your stainless steel the phone from the prime is and
matthew us on
for me as a few are for a couple with
so will continue to of and will both that
jump she arrive wish young
ingenuity will private here and
will will get out of the get the truth of
will truth about the crash w  at came
mechanical mini mints
well this is the dough of difficult c or d
just think to say
beacause whatever your purpose is you can
you and expert because you like and came
mechanics indian
the expert and when there is a review what there
years tyrion's
there  simply to many items and then my
level then there will be cars so the sting
season and manage tiny that
shape the finder old so how
deer use a maeyens
toe in major materials that kenbé we
check that off is equally important
you make a wise it so  important that is
the filet work
though the four works but it's not
finished the film any questions with put
what de juice juice juice juice
absolutely particles
the portugal is cancer free times
object which i the idea week and it
not reproduce nou lebbert er  being
racing white time with week and fantasize
wing mirrors
with who don't know about him i do know
what the eyes also some dollar for
fashion b soon an interview
subscribe to day to the institute if
to that i  s that TV